foreign
is up next right here in Nashville
Tennessee James welcome to the show
hello hey what's going on how you doing
I'm doing great uh uh first of all I'd
like to thank you all for taking my call
and thank you for your show it's been
very helpful absolutely glad to hear it
what's going on with you well I sold my
house and um I'm sitting on about 240
000 and uh it's just sitting in a bank
doing nothing for me and also I have
some annuities as well that are matured
which uh
which I'm looking to uh maybe doc I I
can start collecting on that but it's
like a long-term payout you know so I
thought I might start getting that
having all the deposit into a bank
account and maybe dollar cost average
that into some sort of investment that's
uh maybe a diversification of things
that a little higher Mission some more
safe
um how old are you I am 62. all right do
you have any other retirement you have a
nest egg
well I my income is tax free it's
annuity as well and uh from an action I
had been in years ago and uh it's pretty
good uh I mean my income is pretty good
I get about 5500 a month 5500 a month
and that's tax-free and it's all tax
free and is that guaranteed for the rest
of your life or what yes it is yeah okay
and that's essentially your retirement
yeah yeah it is yeah all right well and
you're not you said you sold the house
where are you living now
um actually I'm I've got another place I
just just right across the river here on
the Cumberland River and uh I'm just I'm
doing the same thing here just a little
RV property I'm looking a little more uh
you know more traveling type uh of uh
lifestyle for a while while I can you
know cool tell them too all to do it I
have another property up north which I
was gonna develop it and put a barn on
it make it RV friendly like a seasonal
type uh the property and that is the
property paid off
everything's paid off I'm dead
wonderful okay and what what other money
do you have in in savings you said you
have 240. any other cash well and that's
about it and I have about 60 in the
annuities I was telling you about
they're pretty much matured two of them
are just been letting it ride for the
last couple years because uh when the
jackets here what I want to do with it
and it's a long-term payout too on some
of that probably most of it um so I was
thinking about taking that and like I
said dollar cost and I have that deposit
into an accountant and I find the right
investment have that dollar cost into
you know I'm thinking there could be
some Bargains going on with the way the
economy is it's getting ready to tank or
if it hasn't you know you know well I
like dollar cost averaging and if you
want to do that into mutual funds index
funds you know don't do this into single
stocks or anything volatile but that
would be a good plan and the rest of the
240 if you want to I would if you're
gonna need it liquid cash in the next
few years for anything you're doing I
would put it in a high yield savings
account for now but if you're talking
you know four five six plus years out
you can invest that and I like the idea
of dollar cost averaging it you could
also lump sum it
yeah yeah I'd like to dial across yeah
you know this way I can get them or ride
the market on its way down and a little
bit on its way back up and maybe it'll
sit up and then you go ahead and cash it
all in in a few years and then just you
know live off the rest absolutely
I mean I'll check my lifestyle up a
little bit as uh well I'd be looking at
my future goals James and going all
right do I want to put this towards the
farm that I want to rebuild you know you
want to have liquid cash for that I
don't want it fluctuating in the market
and you take a big hit on it because you
wanted to invest it and all of a sudden
the market dipped a little and now it
hurts emotionally to take that money out
at a loss so leave as much as you need
in cash in a high yield savings account
that'll grow at about three or four
percent right now in a good online high
yield savings account the rest I would
uh put towards those goals whether
that's investing or using way to go man